m
quillan centrafrique on a des conditions
extrêmement favorables pour faire de
l'agriculture
de conservation
on a des terres disponibles il y en a
des qui demande un climat exceptionnel
on a des conditions de marché assez
exceptionnel et en fait on a décidé de
créer un champion de l'agriculture
durable ça permet d'avoir une
agriculture qui concerne des sols mais
ça permet également d'avoir des coûts de
production extrêmement faible et qui
sont la condition pour pouvoir faire
démarrer une agriculture ici
[Musique]
oh
aujourd'hui il n'y a que le secteur
privé qui pourrait développer dans cette
oeuvre parce que nous assistons à cela
depuis des années à travers les aides
alimentaires je ne développe jamais le
secteur au contraire ça vous rend plus
saignant ça un cube dans nos mentalités
dans nos têtes la motrice de l'assister
lui qui a toujours besoin de tendre la
main pour tous et on lui donnerait alors
que quand c'est le privé qui prend la
sphère romain ses autres joueurs
c'est une question de partenariat entre
ceux qui vont investir avec les
producteurs et tout le monde est gagnant
[Musique]